there are renewed concerns about
mother's day gatherings this weekend
with infections climbing in dozens of
states and the u.s death toll from the
coronavirus nearing 1 million this as
the pain and psychological toll of the
pandemic comes into sharper focus about
214 000 children have lost a parent or
primary caregiver to covid michael
george is here with more michael good
morning dana good morning now in a lot
of ways life is returning to normal but
that's not the case for hundreds of
thousands of kids who lost a parent or
caregiver it's being called a hidden
pandemic and now the country is having a
discussion about how to help them
no no
okay carter and crew are among the
nation's coveted orphans their 25 year
old mother died of kovid before she
could hold her infant son delivered by
cesarean section in a louisiana hospital
louisiana is one of 34 hard-hit states
where 200 or more children out of a
hundred thousand lost a parent according
to a recent analysis of cdc data in
california the state legislature has a
proposal to help them so i have a bill
that would provide hope accounts because
those kids they're going to turn 18
and then they won't have parents that
they can rely on and so fortunately we
have social security survivor benefits
for most of those kids not all but many
of them california state senator nancy
skinner's bill would put at least four
thousand dollars in accounts for
children from poor families but that's
just one state the tragedy of kovid is
that it really impacted our low wage
workers who had to still go to work many
of whom were black and brown families
low-income families
and
they were disproportionately they died
in disproportionate numbers so now their
kids have lost a parent to covet
nationally compared to white children
american indian and alaskan native
children were 4.5 times more likely to
lose a parent or a primary caregiver
black children were 2.4 times more
likely and hispanic children were nearly
two times more likely
carter and crew are being raised by
their grandparents but research is also
showing some of those who died left
behind children to be raised in foster
care
now let's talk about the vaccine kids
under the age of five are the only group
not yet eligible the fda plans to
consider emergency authorization next
month according to the cdc about 1200
children have died from covid in the u.s
michelle
michael thank you